[Music]
Turkish authorities have arrested more
than a hundred people accusing them of
having links to terrorism some are
members of the opposition people's
Democratic party it comes less than
three weeks before President redship
type erdogan faces what's expected to be
a tight election race
let's get more on this from Cinema who's
in Istanbul synonym what do we actually
know about the people who were arrested
well the arbucker the main Center for
this operation is the city and according
to the Arbuckle bars Association the
people who have been arrested detained
by the Turkish police are a journalists
right Defenders
and some NGO Representatives along with
a green left party members but according
to the state news agency as they have
reported these people are allegedly
linked to the urban wing of the upload
Kurdistan Workers Party the pkk and they
according to the uh their sources based
on the prosecutor's office these people
are linked to some protests held across
turkey since 2017 some of them have been
allegedly involved in financing the
outdoor Kurdistan Workers Party and it's
Urban Wing a kiseki
we are three weeks away from a
presidential election so the obvious
question is is this political as the hdp
the opposition party is alleging
[Applause]
well cereal this is a tight election and
the Kurdish votes uh will probably be
the king maker for this election both
for the presidential election and the
Parliament uh Parliament parliamentary
members election on May 14th however
these people who have been detained by
the police in more than 20 cities in
Southeastern turkey are most of the
members of the green left party a green
left party is the party that will be
representing the Kurds in the election
as the people's Democratic party the
HTTP known as the pro Kurdish party is
facing a risk of being closed down by
the Constitutional Court the Kurds in
Turkey have established more than eight
parties that have been shot down by the
authorities in the recent Turkish
history that's why they prefer to join
the election not under the banner of the
people's Democratic party but under
green left party and some of of those
people who have been arrested by the
police are lawyers which means they
would be according to their plan they
would be responsible during the election
they would be taking care of the keeping
eye on the ballots and that's why many
now suspect that the government is
targeting the Kurdish votes and this a a
green left party as the main opposition
Alliance do not have a big structure and
organization in the Kurdish cities even
though this Kurdish party is not a
member of the opposition Alliance for
the election they would be taking care
of the bullets they would be keeping an
eye on the ballots and this is important
for the election the vote security of
course all right something we'll have to
keep an eye on then synonym thank you
for your reporting